[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an indian comedy drama film
called bajrangi by jean
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in the hills of sultan per pakistan
lives a six-year-old mute girl named
shahida one afternoon she is playing on
a hill when she accidentally falls off
of it when she doesn't return home by
the end of the day the villagers
organize a search party after hours of
searching they find the little girl on a
branch protruding from the hill she had
been stuck on it for the entire day but
couldn't call for help because of her
disability the following morning her
parents and neighbors discuss what must
be done to help her an older man
suggests they take her to the shrine of
sufi saint nizamuddin aliyah in delhi
india the religious family believes that
a visit to the holy shrine will bring
peace and happiness and most importantly
restore shahidah's speech shahida's
father used to be in the military and
has fought against the indian army he is
sure that he won't be provided with a
visa to india hence her mother razia
takes it upon herself to travel far from
the village for the first time the trip
goes as planned for the most part the
two reach the shrine pay offerings and
get on a train back to their home
country on the return journey the train
stops for repairs at night when everyone
is asleep shahida notices a lamb stuck
in a pit right outside the train she
doesn't think twice before going outside
to help the animal however the train
restarts before she can return to her
mother the little girl runs towards it
but is eventually left behind in a
desperate attempt to go the same way
that her mother did she boards a freight
train but to her dismay it goes in the
opposite direction and stops in
kurukshetra india razia notices her
daughter is missing and stops the train
policemen are appointed to look for the
girl around the tracks where she was
lost however they cannot find her since
shahida has already reached a different
place razia meets her husband who is
worried to death about his daughter they
cannot get an immediate visa back to
india much to their dismay the parents
have no other way but to pray that their
daughter is safe meanwhile shahida is
now lost in a different country with no
way to communicate in a religious
celebration she sees a stranger eating
at a street side restaurant the stranger
is the kind pawan kumar chatravedi who
invites her to have a meal with him
after a few minutes of trying to get her
to talk he realizes that she is mute and
starts calling her money a starving
money finishes the food and follows
pawan around assuming that she was
separated from her parents during the
festival he asks her to stay in front of
a temple pawan is a devout hindu
brahmana and an ardent devotee of lord
hanuman he believes that lord hanuman
will take money home if she stays in
front of his temple when money still
doesn't stop following him he brings her
to the police station but since she
cannot tell them any details about her
parents the police can only wait for
someone to file a missing complaint
don't these people have pen and paper
until her parents are found money needs
a place to stay hence pawan takes her in
on the way to his home in delhi he tells
money to call him mama if she ever talks
in the future he also starts naming
different indian cities asking her to
nod if she knows what city her parents
are in all the passengers on the bus
help him but none of them name cities
outside of india as they talk pawan
tells everyone how he came to delhi for
work a flashback shows the time he was
in high school he was an average student
who could never pass the final
examination all his friends cheated and
went on with their lives but powwon
refused to cheat or lie being a true
devotee of lord hanuman eventually he
passed on his 11th try and came to delhi
to look for work he stayed with his
father's friend pandi a strict hindu who
refused to let the followers of any
other religion enter his house pandy's
daughter rasika offered powwow on a job
at the school she taught at and fell in
love with his innocent persona but being
the strict father he is pandy asked
pauwan to build his own house before
marrying his daughter ever since then
powwon and rasika have been working hard
to collect money the two are bound to
get married sometime next year everyone
on the bus is impressed by his story he
and money reach his home where rasika
receives them in the doorway she is glad
that powwowon is helping a little girl
in need but pandy doesn't feel the same
way he is worried about the possibility
that money belongs to a different
religion pow-won rationalizes that she
is hindu because of her fair skin color
and persuades pandy to let her stay for
a month money cries every day in the
memory of her parents even though
powwowon and rasika treat her like their
own daughter since the entire family is
vegetarian and money is accustomed to
eating meat with every meal she hardly
ever finishes her food one day pauwon
and rasika find her in a muslim
neighbor's home devouring home-cooked
chicken pow-won brings her to a
restaurant that evening and lets her eat
whatever she likes even though eating
meat is against his religion money is
very fond of the glittery bangles they
sell on the street side one day while
walking through a market she innocently
picks up a pack of bangles before being
stopped by the vendor pow-won makes her
return it and takes her to the temple to
apologize to god for stealing as he
teaches her to join her hands money
sneaks into a mosque nearby pauwan is
hesitant to follow her inside but he
does it anyway to his utter surprise he
sees her reading the quran in front of a
shrine for a few minutes he feels like
she betrayed him because he would have
never befriended a muslim but rasika
makes him realize that she is a human
before she is a muslim she hates that
her father discriminates against people
because of their religion and wants
pawan to be different pauan understands
and runs into the mosque to get money
but by now she has already left as he
nervously looks for her she runs to him
and hugs him tightly at that moment he
accepts her entirely overcoming his
irrational fear of going against his
religion that night is a cricket match
between pakistan and india the entire
family watches it on tv cheering for
india except money who cheers when
pakistan scores when the pakistani team
wins the game she dances and kisses
their flag through the tv pawan
approaches her and asks if she is from
pakistan after weeks of shaking her head
to every indian city money finally nods
yes pandi is furious being a muslim was
bad enough but since the girl is from
pakistan he can no longer allow her to
stay at their home pauwon promises to
hand her to the pakistani embassy the
next day however the embassy worker
cannot allow her a visa without a
passport in money's case they don't even
know her real name so a visa allotment
is impossible moreover a riot takes
place in front of the embassy that
closes all visa processing for a month
as a last resort powwon takes her to a
travel agent at pandy's suggestion the
agent promises to take the little girl
to the other side of the border and asks
for one lock rupees powon and rakusa
give up the funds they had collected for
their house to help money the next day
pow on reluctantly brings money to the
travel agent's office and leaves after a
tearful farewell on his way home he
notices a street vendor selling glittery
bangles he remembers that money liked
them and buys one for her however on
returning to the travel agent's office
he finds out that he has been cheated
the agent has taken the little girl to a
brothel and is about to sell her into
prostitution the otherwise composed
powwon loses his temper at the sight of
the agent counting bills that he made
from money he throws the man out of the
window and brings money home again powon
has made the decision to bring money
home himself although he has no
connections or ideas about pakistani
villages he packs his bag and makes his
way to the border a few miles away from
it they meet a secret agent named ali
who illegally transports people to the
other side through a tunnel after
listening to money's story he agrees to
take them for free when they reach
pakistan's side of the border ali runs
away but being a devotee of lord hanuman
pawan refuses to go without asking the
guards for permission when the officers
find him they beat him up as money
watches and cries pawan pretends to
laugh even while being beaten so the
little girl wouldn't be afraid after
finding out the reason for his travel
the head soldier asks him to do whatever
he wants in the following 10 minutes
before they return for the next round
powwon decides to wait for them because
they have still not permitted him to
leave although the idea is idiotic and
he gets beat up again he is eventually
allowed to go with permission from the
soldiers in the following scene he and
money are in a restaurant money sees a
cop's handcuffs and steals them assuming
that they are a bracelet the cop finds
out and throws pawn in jail labeling him
as an indian spy because of the lack of
a passport
then we are introduced to a struggling
journalist chand nawab he finds out
about the alleged spy and runs to the
police station to interview him he gets
a few vague answers from pauwan and
informs the media company that he
doesn't take him seriously inside the
police station a cop interrogates powwon
but refuses to believe anything he has
to say suddenly money sees a picture on
a table calendar and recognizes it as
her village pauan is overjoyed until the
policeman forcefully makes money open
her mouth pauwon loses his temper and
attacks the man inviting even more
trouble for himself he manages to defeat
the officers and run away from the
police nawab sees him escaping and
follows him they board the bus where
powon shows the conductor their
destination and also tells him money's
story after finding out he is actually a
good person nawab and the rest of the
travelers decide to help him they hide
him and money on top of the bus when the
police come looking for them at night
nawab powon and money stay at a mosque a
religious scholar named azad also helps
them and hides them from the policeman
searching the entire city for the
alleged spy one of azad's students sees
switzerland written on the picture that
money thought was her village the group
is back to square one after that azad
dresses up pawan and nawab in a burqa
and manages to send them outside the
city without the police noticing pauwon
who was oblivious to esam a few weeks
ago feels strange in their traditional
clothing he apologizes to his god but is
ready to do anything for money with that
attitude pow on could become a rapper
for the next few days powwon and nawab
take money to several different places
asking people if they know her nawab
documents their journey and everything
about money and pow-won's relationship
he tries selling the documentary to news
channels but they refuse to air it
claiming that it is boring they have to
find another way to spread the news so
that people on the internet can help one
day they go to a famous mosque where
they find policemen looking for them
nawab realizes that his cameraman friend
is being used by the police to gather
information about their whereabouts the
trio immediately runs away from the holy
place and gives the cameraman false
information to distract the police
following that the group is reviewing
the footage from their time at the
mosque when money recognizes her mother
in one of the clips they see her getting
into a specific bus and go to that bus
driver the very next day upon inquiring
he names all the villages that come on
his daily route one of them is sultan
purr which money confirms is her home
nawab and pawan hag having finally found
their destination nawab also uploads the
video documentary on youtube and the
police get a hint of their location
through it on their way to sultanpur the
bus is stopped to be checked with no way
out pawan comes in the police's view and
pretends to run away while the men are
busy trying to catch him nawab takes
money and brings her back to her village
in the following scene we see money run
to her mother who couldn't be happier to
see her as she reunites with her family
somewhere else pawan gets beaten up by
the police the documentary on youtube
goes viral and the bigger news channels
start covering the story eventually
people find out that powon is not a spy
and is being held in prison for helping
a little girl both indian and pakistani
people give him all of their support but
the pakistani officials refuse to let
him go they torture him in prison
beating him up for hours drowning him
until his last breath and starving him
nawab then claps back with another video
this time on a bigger platform asking
people to gather at the border and
ensure that pauwan reaches home safely
the plan works and several people from
both sides come to the border in crowds
rasika and her family are also among the
crowd waiting for him to come home
eventually the officials have to back
down the crowd erupts chanting pawan's
name as he crosses the border then we
see money among the crowd waving her
hands but unable to call him all of a
sudden she shouts mama the name powwon
wanted her to call him when they first
met
the crowd goes silent as she yells
goodbye pow on turns around in shock the
movie ends as they run to each other and
hug subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching